gute vorsätze fürs neue jahr
das hast du dir fürs neue jahr
vorgenommen
was hast du dir fürs neue jahr
ich habe mir vorgenommen mehr sport zu
treiben
ich habe mir vorgenommen gesünder zu
essen
ich habe mir vorgenommen ein radrennen
zu gewinnen
ich habe mir vorgenommen einen neuen job
zu finden
ich habe mir vorgenommen eine weltreise
zu machen
[Musik]
und du was hast du dir für das neue jahr
vor
und du was hast du dir fürs neue jahr
vorgenommen
ich habe mir vorgenommen mein studium
abzuschließen
ich habe mir vorgenommen nicht mehr bei
der arbeit einzuschlafen
der
arbeit einzuschlafen
ich habe mir vorgenommen morgens früher
aufzustehen
ich habe mir vorgenommen im
deutschunterricht besser aufzupassen
wo lernst du deutsch
in der halle deutsch schule
in der halo deutsch schule
du sprichst aber schon sehr gut
danke
der unterricht macht spaß und man lernt
sehr viel
danke
der unterricht macht spaß und man lernt
sehr viel
ich hoffe dass du alle deine vorsätze
gelingen
danke gleichfalls
leider habe ich letztes jahr zu schnell
aufgegeben
danke gleichfalls
leider habe ich letztes jahr zu schnell
aufgegeben
woran lag es denn
ich hatte sehr viel zu tun
dann habe ich meine vorsätze einfach
vergessen
ich hatte sehr viel zu tun
habe ich meine vorsätze einfach
vergessen
was willst du tun um diesmal
durchzuhalten
dieses mal werde ich ein tagebuch führen
um meine fortschritte täglich
aufzuschreiben
dieses mal werde ich ein tagebuch führen
um meine fortschritte täglich
aufzuschreiben
na sieh mal das ist ja noch ein weiterer
vorsatz
vielleicht sollte ich das auch einmal
ausprobieren
es ist schwierig vorsätze einzuhalten
ohne
selbst zu kontrollieren
es ist schwierig vorsätze einzuhalten
ja das stimmt
da ist ein schreibwarenladen
da können wir tagebücher kaufen
gibt es da nicht eine app
dann hat man es immer dabei
ja aber ein echtes tagebuch ist doch
etwas besonderes
ein besonderes buch für besondere vor
so
ein besonderes buch für
vorsätze
okay lass uns mal sehen was sie haben
pläne für den feierabend
guten morgen guten morgen
was hast du jetzt vor
ich bin auf dem weg zur arbeit
do
ich bin auf dem weg zur arbeit und du
ich gehe auch zur arbeit was hast du
heute
vor
ich gehe auch zur arbeit was hast du
heute
vor
ich weiß noch nicht
willst du etwas unternehmen
was hältst du davon ins kino zu gehen
was hältst du davon etwas essen zu gehen
was hältst du davon im fitnesszentrum zu
trainieren
hast du lust tom zu besuchen wir wollen
ihn zum geburtstag überraschen
hast du lust traum zu besuchen wir
wollen ihn zum geburtstag überraschen
wir haben auch schon ein geschenk
gekauft
du kannst dich daran beteiligen anstatt
ein eigenes
offen
du kannst dich daran beteiligen
ein eigenes zu kaufen
oh ja
da mache ich mit
wo sollen wir uns treffen
wir treffen uns um 5 uhr im sun dogs in
der rheinstraße
danach gehen wir zusammen in toms büro
danach gehen wir zusammen in trance büro
ich werde da sein
super ich sage den anderen bescheid hast
du auch kommst
super ich sag den anderen bescheid dass
wer kommt denn alles
sergio heike d
und ich
sergio heike du
übrigens
was habt ihr für ein geschenk gekauft
ein wochenende im biohotel
hh gute idee
bis heute abend bis heute abend
wo ist felix
ist er unter dem krankenwagen
ist er in der badewanne
ist er auf dem dach
wo ist felix
wie fährt felix in den urlaub
fährt er mit dem auto
fliegt er mit dem flugzeug
nimmt er den zug
wie fährt felix in den urlaub
was ist felix
ist er einen hund
ist er eine katze
ist er eine maus
ist er ein
hitchcock
ist er
ist er einen baum
ist er einen diamanten
ist er bananen
ein
er ist einen kuchen
nein
was trinkt felix
trinkt er eine cola
trinkt er einen kaffee
trinkt er ein glas bier
trinkt er eine flasche wodka
bringt er ein aquarium
trinkt er ein aquarium
nein
er trinkt einen johannisbeersaft
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video